have some observations that you wish to
make about that volume but before you do
so we will observe a minute silence in
honor of the 22 who were killed in the
attack
so that marks one minute would everyone
now please sit
foreign
volume of my report I deal with three
topics
the radicalization of salmon abedi
the planning and preparation for the
attack by Salman abedi and Hashima bedi
and whether the attack could have been
prevented by the security service and
counter-terrorism policing
While most public interests will focus
on whether the attack could or should
have been prevented and the role of the
security service
the significance of the other two topics
should not be underestimated
it is important that we understand as
much as we can about the radicalization
of Salman abedi
so that similar signs can be recognized
and appropriate action taken
it is also important that we know in
detail about the preparation for the
attack
so that measures can be brought
which would which would have prevented
The Killers acquiring the knowledge and
materials they needed to carry out the
attack
radicalization
the inquiry heard evidence from Dr
Wilkinson
his evidence detailed the differences
between followers of mainstream Islam
who are the overwhelming majority and
are accepting of an exist peacefully
alongside people of different faiths and
those he identified as violent islamist
extremists who believe in a narrow
in-group
who believe they are the only ones with
the correct world view
they are prepared to use violence
against members of outgroups
which includes anyone who is not part of
the in-group including mainstream
Muslims
it is important that I emphasize as did
Dr Wilkinson
that the violent islamist extremists are
a tiny group
who've adopted a distorted view of Islam
based on an incorrect interpretation of
the Quran
Dr Wilkinson outlined what he believed
were the various influences that had
contributed to Salman obedi's
radicalization
he concluded that by 2017
every conceivable radicalizing malign
presence and noxious absence existed in
Salman abady's life
he said
I have never seen such a complete
picture of the petri dish absolutely
brimming with germs
I consider that Dr Wilkinson's evidence
was important
his perspective of the significance of
behaviors exhibited by Salman abedi was
on occasions different from that of the
security service and counter-terrorism
policing
I would hope that his evidence will be
considered with Care by the relevant
authorities to see what knowledge can be
regained to assist in the correct
identification of individuals who are at
risk of being radicalized
I have concluded that there were a
number of contributing factors to Salman
abadi's radicalization
his family background and his parents
extremist views along with their
participation in the struggle in Libya
played a significant part
that struggle involved people who were
Radical violent extremists
during the time Salman abedi and Hashima
bedi spent in Libya
during which they were probably involved
in fighting
they are likely to have come into
contact with a number of violent
extremists
it is likely that those extremists
including members of the Islamic State
who would be in a position to provide
the brothers with expertise in making of
bombs and in carrying out
counter-surveillance measures
as leading Council for the inquiry said
during one of the hearings
how was someone of salmon abated limited
intelligence and abilities able to
succeed in committing this atrocity
despite any safeguards which were in
place
the likely answer is
he was provided with help
I have not been able to obtain a
complete picture of the part Samuel
abedi and Hashima bedi's family played
in their radicalization
nor of what happened while they're in
Libya
that is because other members of their
family
namely their parents and brother were
not willing to give evidence to the
inquiry
Salman and hashim's parents were invited
to provide statements but declined to do
so
as they are currently out of the
jurisdiction there were no further steps
that I could take
Ishmael abedi who was in the country at
the time I requested a statement managed
to leave the United Kingdom so that he
didn't have to provide information which
he was in a position to give
I have included in the recommendations
section of volume 3. some suggestions
which I hope will make this more
difficult for important Witnesses in the
future
whether if I had succeeded in getting
Ishmael abedi into the witness box
he would have assisted the inquiry is
very doubtful
what I was not prepared to do in the
circumstances of this case was to invite
the Attorney General to Grant him
immunity from prosecution in relation to
any evidence he gave to me
in order to encourage him to speak
if he was involved in the plot it would
be quite wrong for him to have any
protection from prosecution and
Punishment
there were other extremists most of whom
came from the same area of Manchester as
Salman abedi and probably played a part
in family's radicalization and or
confirming him in his views once he had
committed to Violent extremism
one of those is Abdul rayuth Abdullah
a series of messages over a thousand in
number between Abdul rayuth Abdullah and
Salman abedi sent during November 2014.
were recovered as part of operation
oliban
which was the counter-terrorism policing
investigation which resulted in the
prosecution and conviction of Abdul
Rahul fabdullah for terrorist defenses
those messages talk of martyrdom
they were highly significant in the view
of Dr Wilkinson as demonstrating the
influence that Abdullah Abdullah had
over Salman abedi and the development of
his violent extremist mindset
Salman abedi was not identified as one
of the participants in this exchange of
messages until after the attack
and I have concluded on the balance of
probabilities the messages were not
passed to the security service by
counter-terrorism policing as they
should have been
my investigation however have
demonstrated that even if Salman abedi
had been identified and the messages had
been sent to the security service it
would not have affected their view of
Salman abedu
I have not criticized that view taken by
the security service but there is a
learning point which could usefully be
pursued
which is that the attitude of the
security service to those sort of
messages might be informed by the
considerations which Dr Wilkinson
applied
we know that Salman abedi visited Ryu
fabdullah in prison
and also that they communicated by phone
including by use of an illegal mobile
phone which Abdul roof Abdullah had in
prison
it was Apparent from the evidence
that while prisons were alert to the
problem of known radicalizes influencing
other prisoners they paid little if any
attention to the risk that such
prisoners
who may have had a hero status to some
would take the opportunity to radicalize
visitors or encourage those who were
already radicalized in their beliefs
there is no evidence that Abdul rayuth
Abdullah played any part in plotting the
attack
but it is likely in my view that he
provided support for Salman abady's
ideological beliefs and increased salmon
obedience resolve to carry out the
attack
it is important that the prison
Authority do take notice of the risks
that those in prison for terrorist
offenses such as encouraging others to
go and fight abroad May seek to
radicalize their visitors as well as
other prisoners or at least support
their radical views
the government's response to the risks
of radicalization is the prevent program
a review of that program by William
shawcross has just been published and
the government has responded to it
because of that report I did not carry
out an assessment of the effectiveness
of the prevent program during my inquiry
it would have been beyond my terms of
reference to do so
Shaw cross report does deal with issues
of the abated and prevent
and note that neither of them were
referred to prevent
the intelligence and security Committee
of parliament noted the same thing with
surprise
I have looked in detail at the various
occasions when family bedi could have
been referred to revent
I have concluded that he should have
been
I heard evidence that his referral was
considered at one stage but he was not
considerable considered suitable
suitable
there can be no guarantee that Salman
abedi or Hashima bedi would have agreed
to participate in the prevent program
the elder brother Ishmael refused to
engage in any way with counter-terrorism
policing officers when they went to
speak to him in 2015.
I have concluded that there was at least
a period during summer abady's journey
to Violent extremism when he should have
been referred to the program
it is very hard to say what then might
have happened
I have looked at whether the various
educational establishments and mosques
does Salman abedi attended should have
appreciated that he was moving towards
violent extremism and notified the
relevant authorities
I consider that it would have been very
difficult for any of the educational
establishments to be have become aware
of his developing extremism
one of the problems that I have
identified is that while over the period
of his education at different
establishments Salman abedi showed
worrying signs which could have been
related to extremist views there is no
record which goes with the student which
would allow anybody to consider all
those signs together
having a record which passes from school
with a student to college or university
May well be contentious and deciding
what material to include would also be
difficult
nevertheless I do consider that it is
something which should be looked at to
see if a solution can be found
another very contentious part of the
evidence concerned the Manchester
Islamic Center also known as the
Didsbury mosque which salmon abedi
attended on some occasions
I consider it unlikely having considered
all the evidence that salmon abedi was
radicalized at the Didsbury mosque
but some of the evidence given on behalf
of the mosque about the association of
the obedi family with the mosque was
unsatisfactory
it looks as if the Didsbury mosque was
trying to distance itself from the abedi
family in a way which I did not accept
was accurate
the reality in my view was that the
Didsbury mosque did have a significant
number of attendees who were connected
to Libya but were attached to opposite
sides in the conflict
Didsbury mosque tried and largely
succeeded in providing a broad Church
where both sides of the conflict could
worship together
although conflicts were generally
avoided this did on occasions lead to
tensions between the two sides
the evidence given on behalf of the
ditherbury mosque could have been more
helpful in enabling me to get to the
truth
the charity commission has already
prescribed a program that the Didsbury
mosque must put in place
I hope that they will read my report and
consider whether anything more needs to
be done
for reasons that I've already given I
have not commented on the effectiveness
or prevent at the program
it should be noted however the during my
inquiry several senior police officers
spoke highly of it as a program and how
successful it can be in some cases
William shawcross did comment on the
radicalization of Salman abedi in his
report
he did not have the benefit as I did of
an intensive investigation into salmon
abated case
nor did he have the benefit of hearing
from Witnesses in closed session in
order to resolve contentious issues
insofar as William Shaw course's short
passage in his report dealing with
Salman abedi does not agree entirely
with the conclusions that I have reached
I would suggest that this is because of
the much greater opportunity that I have
had to listen to and test the evidence
planning and preparation
while this part of my report is largely
a narrative event it is nevertheless
important
it is important that what was done by
Salman abadian Hashim obedi in
preparation for the attack is understood
in detail
only by doing that is it possible to
understand where the weaknesses are in
the provisions that try to prevent
people acquiring the necessary
ingredients for a bomb and information
about how to construct it
it is important that the opportunities
for obtaining precursor chemicals are as
limited as possible without preventing
entirely innocent members of the public
conducting their lives without undue
difficulty
this part of the report is based almost
entirely on the work of the operation
manteline team to whom I'm very grateful
this investigation to into the attack
conducted by greater Manchester police
was as far as I am concerned of a very
high quality
it resulted in the conviction of Hashim
abedi for the murder of the 22 people
who died
and the attempted murder of many more
who attended that night
I am as satisfied as I can be that the
brothers made use of an instructional
video placed on the Internet by the
so-called Islamic State to create their
bomb
as much as possible needs to be done by
the authorities to ensure that
instructions for murder such as these
are not put on the internet
and if they are they remain there for
the minimum amount of time
further it is important that the
regulations requiring the reporting of
unusual sales of precursor chemicals are
continually kept under review and are as
stringent as possible
that is not easy to achieve and it needs
to be made clear that unusual purchases
need to be reported promptly
none of the purchases of precursor
chemicals obtained by the brothers were
reported to the authorities
that is the situation which should not
have arisen
had they been reported it is possible
that salmon abedi could have been
stopped
I have considered the parts played by
others in the obtaining of those
precursor chemicals and other acts which
assisted the brothers in their
preparation
all of this was carefully investigated
by the police as part of operation
mandoline and the evidence was reviewed
by the crown prosecution service to
consider whether prosecutions could be
brought
some of the people are still under
police investigation
but so far no further prosecutions have
been brought
the issue in almost every case
is whether the person who in fact
provided help to the brothers in their
preparations can be proved to have known
what they were providing help for
there will inevitably be suspicion and
in some cases there will be more
suspicion than in others
it is not my job to review the charging
decisions of the police or the crown
prosecution service
but for what it is worth I agree with
the decisions that they have made
I do not consider it is appropriate for
me to accuse individuals of serious
criminal offense
where they can't be proved to the
appropriate criminal standard
so I have not gone further than setting
out the way in which various individuals
assisted the brothers
I am confident that if evidence is found
which justifies a prosecution
then the police and the crown
prosecution service will take the
appropriate action
preventability
finally in my report I deal with the
issue of whether the attack should or
could have been prevented by the
security service and counter-terrorism
policing
I have reported fully on those matters
in the closed part of volume 3 of my
report which will be seen by those who
are best placed to ensure that mistakes
which were made are not repeated
in the open part of volume 3
I have included all matters which I can
safely include without jeopardizing
National Security and making our
community less safe
I have set out how I've approached the
issue of National Security and I shall
not repeat it now
except to say
that where it has been possible without
risking National Security to make public
the evidence that I heard enclosed
I have done so
what I have been able to set out in the
open part of volume 3 is that I have
found a significant missed opportunity
to take action that might have prevented
the attack
it is not possible to reach any
conclusion on the balance of
probabilities or to any other evidential
standard as to whether the attack would
have been prevented
however
there was a realistic possibility that
actionable intelligence could have been
obtained which might have led to action
preventing the attack
the reason for this missed opportunity
included a failure by the security
service in my view to act swiftly enough
I am aware that revealing what I have
revealed in part 24 of my report
will leave many people and particularly
the bereaved families wanting to know
more
all I can say is that I have done my
best to reveal what I can
had we not had clothed hearings I would
not have been able to make the findings
that I have been able to make
closed hearings I am convinced were
entirely necessary as part of this
inquiry if it was going to achieve its
aims
the consequence of that however
is that I have not been able to reveal
some of the evidence on which my
findings are based as to do so would
have risked preaching National Security
while I have been critical of some of
the ways of the security service
encountered terrorism police dealt with
the information that they had or could
have had in this case
I also recognize the very difficult job
they have to do and I acknowledge their
success in uncovering a large number of
plots against people in this country
I will make a number of closed
recommendations to try and ensure that
improvements are made in the way that
the security service and
counter-terrorist policing deal with the
intelligence that they get
while I intend to monitor the
recommendations in the open volume 3
I consider that the intelligence and
security Committee of parliament are the
most suitable body to monitor any closed
recommendations that I make
they have already investigated the
attack and made recommendations
they are in the best position to take an
overall View and ensure the steps are
taken to make improvements
they also have the important benefit
that they will be in a position to carry
on their monitoring over a long period
of time
because this is my final open report I
have set out my gratitude to all the
people who have worked so hard on this
report
the lawyers the organizations who have
responded to endless requests for
information
Those Behind the Scenes who have enabled
the inquiry to keep going even in
difficult situations and are include in
that the providers of the technology
which have made it so much easier to
conduct this inquiry
and of course I thank the many many
witnesses who have given evidence to me
all have worked very hard
I am personally especially grateful to
council and solicitors to the inquiry
without whose expertise I could not have
completed what has been a very onerous
task
generally in conducting this inquiry
I have been greatly impressed and
grateful for the genuine intention and
aspiration held by so many to make a
difference
and to try and ensure that nothing like
the Manchester Arena attack ever happens
again
some of the evidence has been
inspirational showing Humanity at its
best
some of it when recounting the
activities of Salman and Hashima bedi
has shown Humanity at its worth
a significant part of the evidence heard
by this inquiry has been grueling and
distressing to listen to
for example the evidence of people who
were there did their best to help
who will be affected for the rest of
their lives by what they saw and heard
the evidence of the bereaved families of
the effect of the deaths of their loved
ones has had on their lives
and who could fail but be moved by the
tributes of the families to those who
died
those who were young were so full of
promise
those who were older were achieving that
and all of them were the cornerstones of
their families
what an appalling loss which was so
unnecessary
amongst all that grief we should try and
remember the positives as well along
with the terrible events
courage of members of the public and
many members of the Rescue Services who
did their best to help in appalling
circumstances
the response of Manchester as it came
together after the attack to support all
those who've been affected
and the efforts of the bereaved families
and survivors to try and make something
good come out of tragedy in their varied
and different ways
I am especially grateful to the bereaved
families for their continuous support
throughout the inquiry
it is impossible to imagine how
difficult it must have been for them to
listen to some of the evidence that we
have heard
I have not been able to answer all of
the questions that they wanted answered
and I'm aware that in my open report on
volume 3 I have raised more questions in
their mind
I am sorry that that was inevitable
I did ask the questions
I did get answers
but for the reasons I have given I have
not been able to report public the what
those answers were
it has been an enormous responsibility
as well as a privilege conduct this
inquiry
I can only hope that we achieve
something by our efforts
that will only happen
if those away away from this inquiry can
share in the desires of those who have
taken part in it to make things better
inevitably some of the changes that are
needed will require money which is in
short supply
but protecting the lives of the people
of this country
must be a high priority for any
government
thank you
Sir John Saunders the the Manchester
Arena bombing inquiry chairman
delivering the third report from that
inquiry remembering today the 22 people
killed and the hundreds injured back in
May 2017.
what a difficult day for those bereaved
families at the third and final part of
the inquiry reaching its conclusion
let's take you through the inquiry's key
findings well it found that the security
services were guilty of a significant
missed opportunity to take action that
might have prevented the bombing inquiry
saying that the security service
received two pieces of intelligence in
the months prior to the attack but their
significance was not fully appreciated
at the time
it also identified problems with the
sharing of information between the
security service and counter-terrorism
police but it concludes that it remains
quite impossible to say whether any
different or additional action could
have prevented the attack
well those are key findings from today
let's speak now to Sky Katarina vitotsi
who has been following this for us from
Manchester uh Katarina what else did Sir
John Saunders say that jumped out at you
this afternoon
directly
well we always knew that this would be
the third and final report and that
within his findings we knew that Sir
John Saunders would look about look at
the preventability of the attack in May
2017 and the role that the intelligence
services and counter-terrorism policing
could have played in preventing that
attack and I think it was important to
pull out some of what he said about it
that he conceded that there was a
significant missed opportunity to take
action that might have prevented the
bombing he said that specifically there
was a security services officer who did
not act swiftly enough and those actions
could have prevented the attack or the
escalation of that attack and he also
recognized that there was a realistic
possibility that actual intelligence
could have been obtained which might
have led to action prevent ending the
attack in May 2017 but I think it was
also a very nuanced statement wasn't it
listening to Sir John Saunders there
there was no definitive
statement saying that the attack would
have been prevented it was was much more
like might and could have been and there
was also an acknowledgment and also an
apology by the chairman of the inquiry
to the families that there was a lot of
detail that he simply couldn't share we
know that evidence has been heard by Sir
John Saunders from the intelligence
Services MI5 and counterterrorism
policing that was her behind closed
doors in the interests of national Intel
National Security and he did apologize
to families saying that in many respects
I acknowledge that there will be more
questions raised by his findings than
perhaps answers specifically with
regards to the preventability but also
important to note that he talks about
the radicalization of Salman abedi and
also about the planning and preparation
of the attack by both the abraidi
brothers salmon and Hashima bedi and I
think it was also interesting how he
referred to the radicalization expert Dr
Matthew Wilkinson who in the inquiry
described the radicalization of Salman
abadi as almost being a petri dish of
germs he said by 2017 every conceivable
radicalizing malign presence existed to
radicalize Salmon obadian directly
quoting Dr Wilkinson saying I have never
seen such a complete picture of the
petri dish absolutely brimming with
germs we knew as I say that this report
would focus on the intelligence services
but there was also lessons to be learned
so John Thorn has said for the prison
Services who didn't take note when
Salman abadi visited Abdul Ralph
Abdullah a convicted Terrace in prison
we knew that there were two meetings
between Simon abedi and Abdul rafab
duller and Sir John Saunders saying
there were lessons to be learned from
the prison Services there and we have
also just in the last few minutes
already had reaction from solicitors
representing many of the families who
lost loved ones in the attack in May and
they've responded to the third and final
report saying deeply painful to read but
also eye-opening there is less
information than we would have wanted
for the reasons I've described but it is
now very clear that there was a failure
to properly assess key intelligence
about Salman abedi and most
catastrophically of all a delay in
acting on it there will be plenty more
reaction to that third and final report
from Mr John Saunders but I think also
just probably time me to take a moment
that even within that report that looked
at those key findings to John Saunders
describing the whole inquiry heard over
many many months here at Manchester
magistrates Court saying it was grueling
and distressing to listen to Listen to
paying tribute to many of the families
who remembered their loved ones either
lost or injured in that attack in May
2017.
Katarina thank you we'll go back to
Katarina following this story from
Manchester in just a few moments time
but if you're just joining us a reminder
of what is unfolding here on Sky News
this afternoon the third report in the
Manchester Arena bombing inquiry has
been delivered within the last few
minutes the main finding is that the
terror attack may have been prevented if
MI5 had acted on key intelligence
received in the months before that in
that attack that's the finding of the
inquiry chair Sir John Saunders two
pieces of information about the suicide
bomber on that night salmon abedi were
assessed at the time by the security
service not to relate to terrorism and
therefore for were not passed on to the
police services let's bring in the
intelligence expert Professor Anthony
glees for his point of view um Anthony
thank you so much for joining us this
afternoon you'll have been listening to
Sir John Saunders they're delivering his
findings
um that headline bit of information
there that's come out the two key pieces
of information that may have prevented
the attack he was very keen to stress
that
um not seen as significant Enough by
security services at the time what's
your assessment of that
well I I thought Sir John saunders's
report was very measured and had a very
fine line to tread you may think but I
have to tell you that I thought it was
less hard-hitting than the evidence
warranted and it wasn't simply you know
two bits of evidence that was missed it
was a whole catalog of volume of
evidence as Professor Wilkinson pointed
out in in terms of the radicalization of
Salman abedi but in countless other ways
significant pointers to the fact that
Salman abedi was a murderous jihadist in
the United Kingdom was simply not taken
seriously by the people who were charged
to deal with it so I I think the
families will feel that they really do
want to know what were the things that
Sir John Saunders said he wasn't at
Liberty to explain to them why uh this
catalog of errors did not lead to Salman
abedi's uh arrest and his emphasis on on
the prevent program
seemed to me to be inappropriate because
it was clear that salmon abedi had
already had access to and done things
that made it virtually certain sooner or
later he and his appalling family would
Mount attack on people in this country
so you've got this story of 22 people
went for a night out a richly deserved
night out with a lovely singer to which
they've been looking forward to who
really at every stage were let down by
the state and against the John Saunders
said well you know the government's got
huge to keep people safe I would say is
the government's primary duty to keep
people safe and if you go through this
with a with a with a fine tooth comb I
think there's some really big questions
structural questions that will have to
be asked about the relationship of MI5
uh with the police about the educational
institutions I mean so John cylinder
says there wasn't a record cap when
someone abedi went to Salford University
for example nobody knew that he'd
attacked a woman in a misogynistic
attack for wearing a short dress nobody
knew that he'd gone to Libya nobody
cared about the fact he'd gone to Turkey
I mean it it what is so striking to
somebody like myself outside is how many
egregious errors were made resulting in
the deaths of of 22 people